عندما تغني ليلة الجمعة
للاحتفال بالذكرى 75 لتأسيس اليونسكو ، فمن ستغني
لأه أنا بالطبع
سأقوم بتمثيل
أفغانستان السابقة التي لم تكن لدينا في
أفغانستان أن الموسيقى
محظورة الآن وسأقوم بتمثيل
بلدي.  الناس الذين تعرفهم الأشخاص
الأبرياء في الواقع بلد حيث
لدينا خمسة
آلاف عام من التاريخ ، لدينا فن
لدينا موسيقى لدينا حياة وهذا ما
أريد أن أمثله للعالم ، هناك
هؤلاء
الموسيقيون المغنون لا يزالون داخل
أفغانستان الذين تبقى معهم
المس ما يخبرونك به بشأن ما
يحدث
بصراحة ، إنه لأمر مفجع أن تسمع
قصصهم في الوقت الحالي ، فأنا أعرف الكثير من
الموسيقيين والمغنين بالطبع
أخبرتهم طالبان رسميًا
أنهم بحاجة إلى التوقف عن عزف الموسيقى وأنهم
بحاجة إلى العثور على مهنة جديدة والآن  أنت
تعرف ما الذي يمكنهم فعله ، كل ما يعرفونه طوال
حياتهم هو الموسيقى
مثل بقية العالم ،
لقد فوجئت بكابول المليئة
بالفرار وسط
تلك الفوضى الشديدة  مشاهد تيك في
المطار ، كيف تشعر أنك
مضطر لمغادرة
العشرين عامًا الماضية ، اعتقدنا أن الأمر
انتهى ، اعتقدنا أنك تعلم أخيرًا أننا
تمكنا من التقدم خاصة عندما
يتعلق الأمر بحالة حقوق المرأة
في أفغانستان ، ثم فجأة انتهى كل
شيء  لقد تم أخذها بعيدًا عنهم ويبدو الأمر
وكأنه حلم ، إنه لا
يشعر وكأنه حقيقة واقعة ، إنه أمر مروع حقًا
ما هو الأمل الذي لديك في المستقبل.
أنهم مسؤولون أيضًا عن
الوضع
شكرًا جزيلاً لك